si nous n'avons pas tous la chance
d'être encore en vacances certains
d'entre vous sont déjà sur la plage les
doigts de pieds en éventail mais comment
tu fais pour mettre des tongs et s'il
était rime avec farniente il est quand
même important de se protéger soleil
chaleur piqûre d'insectes ou de Méduse
quels sont les meilleurs moyens de
passer un été en pleine santé première
chose il faut se protéger des rayons du
soleil casquette chapeau Bob mais
surtout appliqué une bonne crème solaire
et pour ceux qui auraient tendance à
tourner toute la journée au rosé il est
important de rappeler qu'il est
essentiel de s'hydrater avec au moins un
litre et demi d'eau par jour pour une
personne
dans 20 ans elle n'aura plus enfin
attention aux piqûres de moustiques de
guêpes ou même de Méduse en cas
d'allergie il est important d'adopter
les bons réflexes et de ne pas tarder à
appeler le SAMU en cas de fortes
réaction ce soir le docteur Gérald
kerzeek va vous donner tous les conseils
santé pour passer un été en toute
sérénité
bonsoir docteur
on veut tout savoir parce que là on part
en vacances dans peu de temps alors
commençons par les méduses moi on m'a
toujours dit quand tu te fais piquer par
la Méduse
et pourquoi alors je ne sais pas
lorsqu'on a envie je ne sais pas alors
est-ce que c'est vrai ou pas non c'est
pas vrai l'idée c'était de d'amener de
la chaleur parce qu'en fait la méduse ça
neutralise la toxine quand on apporte de
la chaleur et quand vous pissez sur le
pied c'est à 37 degrés donc ça apporte
une source de chaleur mais bon c'est pas
très hygiénique évitez de faire ça à la
plage on va vous prendre pour quelqu'un
de bizarre donc une méduse et alors déjà
c'est la prévention on fait gaffe c'est
pas des sacs plastiques qui traînent sur
la mer on écarte un peu et surtout sur
ces piquets quand on est en train de
nager on sort tout de suite ça évitera
le malaise et ça évitera de se noyer et
la deuxième chose c'est qu'on met avec
de l'eau de mer dans un dans un seau et
vous allez rincer la blessure puisque ça
c'est très
à l'eau de mer extrêmement important et
le troisième truc important vous mettez
du sable et vous sortez une carte
postale une carte bleue ce que vous
voulez et vous allez gratter dessus je
fais piquer sur la main par exemple vous
allez mettre du sable dessus et vous
allez gratter et ça va enlever
ça devrait bien se passer une question
pourquoi tu ne pas utiliser l'eau douce
alors c'est une histoire de pression en
fait si vous mettez de l'eau douce il y
a pas de sel et s'il y a pas de sel ça
va faire éclater les petites vésicules
et ça va ajouter le fait de se gratter
donc voilà pourquoi il y a pas de danger
de mort avec les méduses non sauf si
vous êtes allergique on peut faire des
réactions allergiques et ça veut dire
que si vous commencez à gonfler ou
doubler de volume vous avez du mal à
respirer vous êtes très allergique
évidemment vous appelez le 15 le SAMU ou
vous allez voir votre pharmacien mais
dans l'immense majorité des cas du
paracétamol doliprane tout ira bien ça
va passer quelques heures
antihistaminique si on veut qu'ils sont
des anti-allergiques ça va surtout
éviter de se gratter et puis on
conseille d'aller voir son pharmacien
mais pas n'importe quoi c'est comme les
brûlures il y a des gens qui mettent
encore de la pomme de terre qui met du
dentifrice dessus
on va avoir son pharmacien et c'est lui
qui va conseiller la bonne pommade etc
alors on en parle souvent d’été ça pose
parfois de vrais problèmes et même
parfois ça amène à la mort les datations
il faut effectivement boire
régulièrement quand il fait très chaud
et ce qu'il faut boire froid non on boit
pas glacer l'idée c'est d'éviter le choc
thermique si vous avez une certaine
température et l'être humain il est à 37
degrés plus ou moins quelque chose si
vous buvez glacé le cœur à un moment
donné il va mal supporter il va pas
comprendre et il va essayer de s'adapter
et si vous avez un coeur fragile ça peut
être embêtant c'est le principe de
l'hydrocution quand vous plongez dans la
flotte vous étiez sur la plage
tranquille vous montez en température 37
38 vous allez l'estomac un petit peu
plein vous allez dans de l'eau qui est
plus froide et bien vous risquez un choc
thermique donc on s'hydrate mais pas de
l'eau glacée l'eau à température moi
quand j'étais petit on est toujours ne
va pas te baigner après avoir mangé on
se mouille le coup on se mouille un peu
la même chose
parce que l'idée c'est de c'est
d'habituer son corps à avoir une
température et pas avoir des variations
brutales de température il y a une
question de Monsieur Jean-Michel aime
qui souhaite regarder de la nénua et tu
devrais qu'il faut aider le rosé à la
plage bah ouais parce que ça hydrate pas
je sais pas si c'est non c'est pas vous
la bière le rosé on évite tout ce qui
est alcool parce qu'on a l'impression
que ça va hydrater et en fait ça
déshydrate donc le mieux c'est l'eau on
évite aussi tout ce qui est sucré on
peut prendre un peu mais l'eau c'est
quand même la meilleure manière de
s'hydrater et on peut pas trop très
souvent quand nous on a des gens aux
urgences qui arrivent non pas à cause de
la canicule parce qu'ils sont des
hydratés mais ils arrivent parce qu'ils
sont hyper hydratés en outre en outre 5
litres 6 litres et là on sait jamais
raison de dire ça on se noie
complètement de l'Intérieur
maxi par jour
est-ce qu'on peut boire
est-ce qu'on peut voir les gars c'est
pas grave
alors ça se concernant alors concernant
le soleil ça c'est aussi un on a pas le
temps tout l'été alors on est tout le
temps il faut préparer sa peau au soleil
vrai ou faux
oui c'est vrai enfin faut surtout
s'exposer progressivement pas trop
s'exposer et mettre des produits qui
vont être des indices de protection
élevés au départ pour la protéger si
votre question c'est ce qu'il faut faire
des UV avant
c'était un peu pour monter qui n'est pas
là mais non parce qu'on a un capital en
fait soleil on a un capital pour prendre
des coups de soleil souvent se capital
on l'a grillé quand on est également
donc le réflexe déjà pour les parents
c'est de protéger les enfants mais ce
capital soleil si vous faites des UV
avant l'exposition solaire vous allez le
griller par les UV et le griller
l'exposition solaire donc on fait pas du
V quand on dit indice 50 est-ce que
c'est vrai que ça veut dire qu'on peut
rester 50 minutes au soleil oui ah c'est
ça oui ça veut dire ça ça veut surtout
dire
que ça vous protège avant coup de soleil
et que ça n'empêche pas totalement le
coup de soleil c'est pour ça qu'il y a
quelques années on disait c'est un écran
total et en fait les gens pensaient ah
bah ça y est je suis protégé pendant des
heures non il faut renouveler
l'application l'écran total ça n'existe
pas et au début de l'exposition on met
du 50
on va descendre et puis entre quelqu'un
qui est blond ou quelqu'un qui a une
peau très matte c'est différent là aussi
donc si on est fragile blond aux yeux
bleus etc c'est vraiment de la 1050
quasiment tout le temps et puis quand on
a une peau qui est un peu plus habitué
on peut on peut diminuer un peu mais ça
ne protège pas totalement et surtout si
vous allez dans l'eau il faut renouveler
l'application régulièrement alors
maintenant il y a une grande mode on
conseille notamment aux enfants de se
baigner avec des combinaisons anti-UV
c'est bien ça ou pas
et c'est surtout pour les retrouver
comment ça non mais c'est pas une bêtise
c'est pas une connerie c'est pour les
voir aussi les enfants qu'on a mis ça
alors déjà il faut jamais les perdre de
vue ça c'est le premier truc ce qui est
bien
ah regardez pas vos enfants
normalement c'est lui
surtout dans la flotte non mais ce qui
est bien c'est penser au réflexe
prévention et de pas de pas avoir des
coups de soleil chez les enfants donc
après je suis pas sûr que ça soit très
confort ou très saillant pour les gamins
ou très confortable une petite astuce
pour les enfants qui ont reçu parfois on
perd ses enfants sur la plage parce
qu'on est ils ont échappé à surveillance
pendant quelques secondes et j'avais vu
reportage avec des CRS il faut toujours
les chercher un enfant va toujours
marcher d'autres soleils j'ai même
marché face au soleil donc il faut
chercher dans l'autre sens du soleil ça
n'a jamais marché les yeux en fait du
soleil tu savais pas ça des recherches
les piqûres de moustiques il y a pas
grand chose à faire malheureusement non
il y a rien mais les piqûres de
moustiques ça va gonfler un peu il y a
des gens qui sont plus réactifs ils sont
pas allergiques mais ils sont réactifs
et vous faites piquer sur la main et la
main elle va un peu gonfler ça peut
faire une cloque rouge etc tant que
c'est pas tout le bras tant que vous
n'avez pas doublé de volume il y a pas
de risque d'allergie les piqûres de
guêpes par contre c'est plus embêtant
c'est piqué par une piqûre de guêpe et
que vous mettez vraiment avoir une
grosse réaction voir si vous avalez une
guêpe et ça c'est le truc comme ça mais
bien sûr et d'ailleurs regardez toujours
dans vos canettes là avant de le prendre
à la bouche ou dans le verre avant de
boire si vous faites piquer à la gorge
allergique ou pas vous sucez des glaçons
ça paraît con à dire mais le fait de
sucer de la glace ça va diminuer le DM
ça va permettre de ralentir le DM qui va
arriver forcément et d'appeler les
secours alors on a une vidéo de d'un
couple qui a inventé une machine
révolutionnaire contre les moustiques
regardez ah bon
[Musique]
la borne anti-moustique va simuler la
respiration humaine pour attirer mon
site donc la respiration humaine c'est
deux composantes c'est l'expiration qui
CO2 et c'est notre odeur corporelle qui
est expiré par notre corps et donc on va
simuler ces deux composantes là ici ça
va indiquer à la femelle moustique qui a
en recherche d'un repas à Saint-Cloud
qui est quelqu'un piqué à l'intérieur de
la banque et donc elle s'approche et
dans sa course elle s'est fait aspirer
ici le moustique se retrouve piégé à
l'intérieur du fil on brise comme ça le
cycle de reproduction puisque chaque
femelle qui est en presse de chercher un
individu à piqué et bien elle est en
capacité de prendre 200 œufs toutes les
48 heures alors pas mal ça c'est pas
grand public je pense que c'est cher
dans quelques restos et franchement ça
change la vie c'est génial mais sinon le
plus efficace
en rond là c'est ça
ah oui
je te dis c'est pas dramatique le
moustique même si c'est non d'accord il
faut éviter par contre c'est les pneus
avec de l'eau qui stagne etc parce que
ça c'est des nids à moustiques donc il
faut vraiment éviter ça sur la page avec
un pneu non j'ai pas de pneu il y a des
maisons il y a ça on va parler de la
gueule de bois quand on est en vacances
malheureusement à consommer avec
modération et parfois bon on exagère un
petit peu et le lendemain on est pas
bien qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour
éviter la gueule de bois on va voir
continuez à voir alors moi alors moi ma
grand-mère disait c'est après une cuite
la veille le lendemain tu rattaque à la
bière exactement
la gueule de bois alors déjà il y a
aucun médicament qui fonctionne contre
la gueule de bois donc parfois on voit
des publicités toutes les études ont
montré qu'il y a aucun médicament
efficace la gueule de bois c'est la
déshydratation donc le meilleur moyen
c'est de le rater et pour éviter la
gueule de bois c'est boire avec
modération je peux évidemment mais ça
veut dire qu'on peut alterner un verre
d'alcool avec un verre d'eau un verre
d'alcool un verre d'eau donc ça c'est
déjà pas mal parce que ça hydrate et en
plus ça évite de trop boire d'alcool et
le deuxième truc c'est que le
paracétamol marche très bien si vous
avez un peu à la tête vous pouvez vous
hydrater prendre un peu de parallèle
malheureusement en tant que parents et
quand on était enfant c'est le fameux
mal des transports c'est-à-dire que la
peau de renard quand elle est dans la
voiture que ton fils derrière dit papa
papa
pour éviter ça m'accrocher du persil
autour du cou comme quoi il y a un gros
effet placebo quand même je vous assure
que je ne sais pas avec une gousse de
persil vous imaginez la station essence
on a l'air
les amis l'idée c'est on mange pas trop
mais on part pas l'estomac vide donc on
mange pas trop on évite les produits
lactés avant de prendre la voiture on
évite les jeux vidéo de lire en voiture
parce qu'en fait c'est un problème entre
l'oreille interne et l'oeil et donc si
vous avez une information visuelle avec
le paysage qui défile mais vous êtes
assis dans la voiture votre oreille
interne elle dit bah non tu bouges pas
finalement alors que là il dit
exactement l'inverse il y a des gens qui
sont beaucoup plus sensibles donc ça
veut dire qu'il faut quand même fixer un
point lointain fixer l'horizon et puis
on ouvre les fenêtres on a air et il y a
des gens qui sont potentiels
ça fonctionne il y a pas de problème à
la limite si ça fonctionne avec le gamin
pourquoi pas moi je vous dis le persil
je suis pas sûr que c'était lié au
persil mais je pense que
psychologiquement on me disait c'est
vachement bien etc tu vas voir tu vas
pas vomir merci beaucoup